PEOPLE ARE NOT LISTENING TO FAKE
NEWS.
THAT IS ALL COMING UP.
VERY IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS,
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
THIS WEEKEND, THE FAKE AND,
WELL, SLOWLY DETERIORATING
"NEW YORK TIMES" PUBLISHED A
CONFIDENTIAL MEMO FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY TO
THE OFFICE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IF LICKED BY SOMEONE ON
MUELLER'S TEAM, THIS IS A HUGE,
CRIMINAL BREACH OF TRUST.
MAYOR GIULIANI THINKS THAT'S A
FACT.
NEITHER THE LEFT OR MAINSTREAM
MEDIA CARE THAT A CONFIDENTIAL
LETTER WAS LEAK FROM ROBERT
MUELLER'S OFFICE TO THE PRESS,
MANY LIBERALS ARE NOW FEIGNING
THEIR MORAL OUTRAGE OVER THE
CONTENTS, ESPECIALLY THIS
PARAGRAPH OF THE LEGAL TEAM'S
VIEW OF OBSTRUCTION AND THE
PRESIDENT'S POWER TO PARDON.
"THE PRESIDENTS ACTIONS HERE BY
VIRTUE OF THIS POSITION OF CHIEF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER CANNOT
CAUSE ACUTE OBSTRUCTION BECAUSE
THAT WOULD AMOUNT TO HIM
OBSTRUCTING HIMSELF AND HE
COULD, IF    IF YOU WISH, TERMIA
COULD, IF    IF YOU WISH, TERMIE
THE INQUIRY OR PARDON IF YOU
DESIRED."
THIS ECHOES WHAT ATTORNEY AFTER
ATTORNEY OR ATTORNEY HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU RIGHT HERE ON THIS
PROGRAM NOW FOR MONTHS.
AS PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS LEGAL TEAM, THEY DO HAVE THE
POWER TO LITERALLY ORDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
ACTUALLY INITIATE AN
INVESTIGATION, END AND
INVESTIGATION, BY THE WAY, FOR
WHATEVER REASON, THAT IS WHAT
THE PRESIDENT'S CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY.
EVEN THE DOJ ADMITS THEY CANNOT
CHARGE A SITTING PRESIDENT WITH
OBSTRUCTION.
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IT?
ALSO, THE PRESIDENT'S POWER TO
PARDON, EVEN HIMSELF, ABSOLUTE
POWER.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THAT IS
CLINTON SYCOPHANT TURNED
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS, YOU CAN SEE THEM
WHISPERING IN CLINTON ABBAS RISK
HE ASKED RUDY GIULIANI,
DONALD TRUMP'S ATTORNEY, FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR, WHAT IS A
COMPLETELY NONSENSICAL TOTALLY
HYPOTHETICAL AND, FRANKLY,
RIDICULOUS QUESTION ABOUT THIS
VERY CONCEPT.
IT IS IRRELEVANT TO EVERYTHING
IN THE REALITY THAT IS
HAPPENING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU AND THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEYS BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
HAS THE POWER TO PARDON HIMSELF?
>> HE'S NOT, BUT HE PROBABLY
DOES.
HE HAS NO INTENTION PARDONING
HIMSELF.
NOT TO SAY HE CAN'T.
I MEAN, THAT'S A REALLY
INTERESTING CONSTITUTIONAL --
CAN THE PRESIDENT PARDON HIMSELF
CAN THE PRESIDENT PARDON HIMSEL
HIMSELF?
IT WOULD BE AN OPEN QUESTION.
I THINK IT WOULD PROBABLY GET
ANSWERED BY, GOSH, THAT'S WHAT
THE CAUSE EDITION SETS, AND IF
YOU WANT TO CHANGE IT, CHANGE IT
YOU WANT TO CHANGE IT, CHANGE I
IT.
I THINK THE POLITICAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT WOULD BE
TOUGH.
PARDONING OTHER PEOPLE IS ONE
THING.
PARDONING YOURSELF IS ANOTHER.
>> Sean: RUDY GIULIANI WAS
KIND OF LAUGHING ABOUT IT.
HE HAS THE POWER, BUT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
LOCALITY MEDIA IS REACTING.
LITTLE GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS
ASKED ALL BEWILDERED.
NOT A NEW CONCEPT OR LET'S GO
BACK DOWN MEMORY LANE, THEN
CANDIDATE 2016 HOT WATER OVER A
GROSS, BLATANT'S USE OF
INFORMATION ON THE MOM AND POP
BATHROOM CLOSET SERVER?
MANY WERE ACTUALLY ARGUING,
THINKING SHE WAS GOING TO BE
ELECTED PRESIDENT IF SHE COULD
RIGHTLY PARDON HERSELF.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE FROM
DAN ABRAMS LAW AND CRIME
WEBSITE.
IF HILLARY CLINTON IS INDICTED,
PRESIDENT CLINTON COULD PARDON
HERSELF AND CONGRESS MIGHT BE
HELPLESS.
THIS ARTICLE FROM
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," "THE
SHORT ANSWER TO WHETHER THE
CAUSE EDITION FROM ITSELF
PARDONING IS, YES, IT PROBABLY
DOES."
BY NO MEANS IT'S AN HONEST
OPINION UPON LEGAL EXPERTS.
THAT RIDICULOUS QUESTION TO
GIULIANI CAME FROM THE SAME GUY
WHO MADE A NAME FOR HIMSELF AS
BEING BILL CLINTON'S POLITICAL
HIT MAN DURING HIS RUN FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS NOW THE SPOKESMAN AND
NEWS PERSON FOR "ABC NEWS."
HE IS NO PETER JENNINGS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CONSIDER WITH FACTS OF
NAMES AND PHONE NUMBERS OF YOU
WHO HAD AN AFFAIR WITH.
IT'S COMPLETELY [BLEEP].
YOU WOULD BE LAUGHED AT.
YOU WOULD THINK YOU ARE CRAZY.
I GUARANTEE YOU IF YOU DO THIS,
YOU WILL NEVER WORK IN
DEMOCRATIC POLITICS AGAIN.
MAYBE YOU DON'T WANT TO.
I'M NOT SAYING IT MATTERS.
YOU WILL BE EMBARRASSED BEFORE
THE NATIONAL PRESS CORPS.
PEOPLE WILL THINK, NOBODY WILL
BELIEVE YOU.
AND PEOPLE WILL THINK YOU ARE
SCUMMY.
>> Sean: GEORGE LOOK SO FAIR
AND UNBIASED.
HE SEEMS LIKE A REAL JOURNALIST
IN THAT VIDEO.
MEANWHILE, RUDY GIULIANI'S
COMMENTS WERE CLEARLY BASED ON
LEGAL PRECEDENT.
EARLIER TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF TWEETED OUT, "AS HAS
BEEN STATED BY NUMEROUS LEGAL
SCHOLARS, I HAVE THE ABSOLUTE
RIGHT TO PARDON MYSELF, BUT WHY
WOULD I DO THAT WHEN I'VE DONE
NOTHING WRONG?"
WHICH BRINGS US TO A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT.
THIS PHONY, FAINT, SO COUNT
OUTRAGE FROM THE LEFT AND THE
MEDIA AND OTHER ANTITRUST
GROUPIES IS OVER SOMETHING
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED AND
SOMETHING THAT WILL NOT HAPPEN
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE
NOTHING WRONG AND IT WAS A
WAS ACTUALLY LAUGHING AT.
STILL, THE MEDIA'S ECHO CHAMBER
BLOWING UP OVER SOMETHING
ROOTED, ILLEGAL PRESIDENTS,
BACKED UP BY REAL CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAS
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAN
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAT
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAE
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HA
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAA
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAP
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAN
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAD
SCHOLARS, YET SOMETHING THAT HAA
PROBABLY WON'T.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE MEDIA ONCE
AGAIN MAKING MUCH TO DO ABOUT
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING, KNOWING THIS
IS THE SAME MEDIA, AS YOU WATCH
THIS, TOTALLY MISSING IN ACTION
ON THE BIGGEST STORY IN THEIR
LIFETIMES, WHICH IS THE LARGEST,
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN U.S.
HISTORY.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY FOCUS ON.
>> A STUNNING STATEMENT FROM THE
PRESIDENT OPENLY DECLARING THAT
HE BELIEVES HE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> TRIED TO PICTURE AN ORDINARY
CRIMINAL WHO COMMITTED A CRIME
SAYING THAT I COULD DO WHATEVER
I WANT, BY THE WAY, I WILL
PARDON MYSELF.
YOU SOUND LIKE YOU ARE GUILTY
WHEN YOU SAY THAT.
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE.
THE PRESIDENT ALL MORNING SAYING
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES IS ABOVE THE LAW
AND IS NOT REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH THE CONSTITUTION OR THE
LAWS OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS STAGGERING.
>> THEY ARE KIDDING THEMSELVES
AND WILL BE A LETDOWN IF THEY
EVER DECIDE TO TRY THIS ON, TO
TAKE THIS AND PUT WHEELS ON
THIS, TAKE IT OUT FOR A SPIN TO
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT?
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME, GO TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
YOU MAY GET ONE, YOU MAY GET TWO
VOTES.
THAT'S IT.
YOU WILL BE RUN OVER.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS TALKING ABOUT
PARDONING HIMSELF ABOUT NOT
BEING INDICTED.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT -- WHAT
INCREDIBLE
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT WOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THE END OF HIS
PRESIDENCY.
IF YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
SAYING I'M GOING TO PARDON
MYSELF EVEN AS REPUBLICANS TRY
TO PROTECT THEM, YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE COLLAPSE IN MANY WAYS
OF THE INSTITUTIONS OF THIS
REPUBLIC.
>> Sean: ANOTHER WEEK, MORE
HYSTERIA, MORE FAINTING MORAL
OUTRAGE, PUSHING THE SAME
SCANDAL FOR PEOPLE WRONG A YEAR
AND A HALF, THEY WANT YOU TO
TRUST THEM.
NO WONDER THEIR APPROVAL RATINGS
ARE IN THE GUTTER.
ALMOST IN SINGLE DIGITS.
JOURNALISM IN THIS COUNTRY IS
DEAD AND BURIED.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE MORE
EVIDENCE YOUR DEEP STATE IS
CRUMBLING RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
LOOK AT    AT THIS CBS NEWS POL.
AMERICANS, THEY LOST CONFIDENCE
IN ROBERT MUELLER'S PROBE FOR
SO-CALLED PROBE.
THEY AGREE WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THE WITCH HUNT NEEDS TO END.
"OBAMA'S BUYING SCANDAL LOOKING
A LOT LIKE WATERGATE."
I KEEP TELLING YOU IT'S
WATERGATE ON STEROIDS.
MICHAEL McKAY Z, SMART BAND,
DRESSING DOWN ONE FORMER
DEEP STATE OPERATIVE AT THE
CENTER OF ALL OF THIS.
LOOK AT WHAT HE SAYS ABOUT
BRENNAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOHN BRENNAN IS GOING TO HAVE
A LOT TO ANSWER FOR WHEN THIS IS
OVER.
BECAUSE, UM, HAYES, UM,
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UM
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN U,
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UP
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UO
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UI
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UG
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UA
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UN
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UI
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UF
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UR
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UA
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UT
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN U,
PARTICIPATION WITH THE CIA IN UO
BE USED IN CONNECTION WITH THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION, IS A
STORY THAT HAS NOT BEEN YET TOL.
THEY GUY WAS THE INFORMANT, YOU
KNOW, A CIA ASSET.
NOT AN FBI ASSET.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW, UM, A
CIA ASSET BECOMES AN FBI
INFORMANT WHO ORGANIZED THAT,
WHO PAID HIM, UM, JOHN BRENNAN
LIKE SOME MULTI-OPERATION
RELATING TO UM...
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I DO NOT KNOW IF HE HAS ANY
CREDENTIALS, IF HE IS A MIND
READER, OR A PSYCHOANALYST.
TO BE ANALYZING THE PRESIDENT'S
MOTIVES.
BUT HIS OWN PERFORMANCE, UM
BUT HIS OWN PERFORMANCE, UM    S
SOMETHING NOT TO WRITE HOME
ABOUT.
>> Sean: THIS IS A SAD MOMENT
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE HOUSE IN TOTAL
-- DEVIN NUNES GAVE AN UPDATE
ON THE DOJ STONEWALLING.
STRONG WORDS FOR HIS COLLEAGUE
INCLUDING HOUSE OVERSIGHT
CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY WHO WAS DEAD
WRONG LAST WEEK AND DIDN'T HAVE
ALL THE INFORMATION HE NEEDED
BEFORE HE MADE THESE COMMENTS.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HE SAID TO
OUR FRIEND MARIA BERTRAM.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDE
>> WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDD
THIS INFORMATION OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING.
WE'VE ATTENDED TWO BRIEFINGS.
THEY WERE VERY SMALL BRIEFINGS.
NOT A LOT OF INFORMATION.
BUT WE WERE HAPPY IT IS
PROGRESS.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION THAT
WE WILL REVIEW THIS WEEK.
WHAT I SAY IS IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO HIDE, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL KNOWS THAT
MR. GAUDI WOULD LOVE TO
EXONERATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI.
THE MEDIA HAS TRIED TO MAKE A
BIGGER DEAL THAN IT IS.
WHAT TREY GOWDY IS SPECIFICALLY
TALKING ABOUT IS THE SMALL SLICE
OF THE INVESTIGATION WE ARE
LOOKING AT AS IT RELATES TO
WHETHER OR NOT INFORMANTS, AN
INFORMANT OR INFORMANTS WERE
USED.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS REFERRING TO.
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT A TARGET OF
THIS INVESTIGATION.
I BELIEVE THAT MR. GOWDY KNOWS
AND HE'S BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING US GETTING TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE FISA ABUSE THAT OCCURRED.
TO BE WHAT WE PEEL BACK THE
ONIONS OF THE DEEP STATE AND
DISMANTLE IT AND WE ARE DOING IT
NIGHT BY NIGHT, BRICK BY BRICK.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON BACK IN
THE NEWS LIKE AN UNWANTED
HOUSEGUEST, BILL CLINTON BACK IN
THE PUBLIC SPOTLIGHT MAKING
MONEY, PUSHING A BRAND-NEW BOOK
THAT IS OFF TO A HORRIBLE START.
WHAT THE -- WE CAN CALL HIM THE
GRANDFATHER OF TODAY'S #MeToo
MOVEMENT.
HE FAILS TO REALIZE IT'S NO
LONGER 1996.
HIS BUDDIES IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO
GIVE THEM A FREE PASS ON HIS
HISTORY OF RAMPANT, HORRIFIC
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, AN INTERVIEW
WITH NBC NEWS, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS PRESSED -- THEY
COULD HAVE DONE THIS BEFORE THE
ELECTION, BUT, OF COURSE, THEY
WANTED HILLARY TO WIN, BUT HE
WAS PRESSED ON HOW HE MISHANDLED
THE MONICA LEWIN SKI SCANDAL,
AND ALMOST ON BELIEVABLY
CLINTON, WHO WAS IMPEACHED
UNDER LIKE UNDER OATH, SAID HE
DID THE RIGHT THING.
PAULA JONES SAID HE DROPPED HIS
PANTS AND GOT NAKED IN FRONT OF
HER BUT WE KNOW THAT JUANITA
BROADDRICK CHARGED HIM WITH RAPE
BROADDRICK CHARGED HIM WITH RAP
RAPE, CATHERINE REALLY TOUCHED
AGAINST HER WILL IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
>> CLINTON SAYS CRITICS ARE NOW
POUNCING IN LIGHT OF THE #MeToo
#MeToo MOVEMENT.
>> A LOT OF THE FACTS HAVE BEEN
CONVENIENTLY OMITTED TO MAKE THE
STORY WORK.
PARTLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
FRUSTRATED THAT THEY GOT ALL
THESE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST THE CURRENT OCCUPANT IN
THE OVAL OFFICE AND VOTERS DON'T
SEEM TO CARE.
I THINK I DID THE RIGHT THING.
I DEFENDED THE CONSTITUTION.
TO BE WHAT WHAT FACT?
TELL US.
YOU LOST YOUR LAW LICENSE, YOU
LOST A JUDGMENT IN THE CASE OF
PAUL JONES AND PAID MONEY.
AND YOU ARE IMPEACHED.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
IN CASE, IT WAS NBC, CRAIG
MELVIN, CONTINUING TO PRESS
CLINTON AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT
COULD JUST NOT TAKE IT, HANDLE
IT, OR EVEN BELIEVE IT.
LIVING BACK IN 1996.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU THINK DIFFERENTLY OR
FEEL MORE RESPONSIBILITY?
>> NO.
I FELT TERRIBLE THEN.
AND I CAME TO GRIPS WITH THAT.
NOBODY BELIEVES THAT I GOT OUT
OF THAT FOR FREE.
I LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE
$16 MILLION IN DEBT.
BUT YOU TYPICALLY HAVE IGNORED
GAPING FACTS, AND I BET YOU
DON'T EVEN KNOW --
B1 HAVE
I'VE NEVER TALKED TO HER.
BUT I DID SAY PUBLICLY ON MORE
THAN ONE OCCASION THAT I WAS
SORRY.
I DEALT WITH IT 20 YEARS AGO
PLUS.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN TERMS
OF THAT HAVE STAYED WITH ME.
AND I'VE TRIED TO DO A GOOD JOB
INSTEAD WITH MY LIFE AND WITH MY
WORK.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY TO YOU.
>> Sean: REMEMBER WHEN HE ONCE
SAID, WE WERE ALONE, ME AND
MONICA, LOOKED OUT IN THE WINDOW
THERE WAS A GIRL IN THE BICYCLE.
YOU NEVER REALLY ARE ALONE, ARE
YOU?
I HAD NOT HAD SEX WITH THAT
WOMAN A SINGLE TIME.
THEY ACTED ABOVE THE LAW, THE
COMPLICIT MEDIA GAVE THEM A
PASS.
THEY IGNORED ALL OF THIS IN THE
26 ELECTION.
BILL CLINTON'S SICK, PERVERTED
HISTORY OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ALONG WITH ALL OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS, WE'VE INTERVIEWED
THESE WOMEN, EVEN RAPE WENT
UNPUNISHED.
THE MEDIA DIDN'T BRING IT UP IN
2016 BECAUSE THEY WANTED HER
ELECTED.
WE KNOW THAT HILLARY WAS A  ,
GRANTED LENIENCY BY JAMES COMEY
AFTER SHE COMMITTED FELONIES,
VIOLATING THE ESPIONAGE ACT,
DELETED EMAILS, ACID WASHED HER
HARD DRIVE, BROKE UP HER DEVICES
WITH A HAMMER, OR HAD A AIDE DO
IT.
YOU THINK ANY EVERY DAY
AMERICANS DID WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON DID OR
BILL CLINTON DID?
WHAT ABOUT THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN HIRING A FOREIGN SPY
COOKING UP A UNTRUE, PROVEN
FALSE, RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE TO
USE RESEARCH AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP QUESTION LIKE
ANYONE IN THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR THAT
RUSSIAN COLLUSION QUESTION MIKE
NO, THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT IS
ONLY INVESTIGATING TRUMP
ASSOCIATES.
THIS IS THE DANGER IN THIS
COUNTRY TODAY IF WE ARE GOING TO
REMAIN A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC, ONE THAT BENEFITS THE
CLINTONS AT EVERY TURN, THEY
HAVE LEFT ALL THE WAY TO THE
BACK.
BY THE WAY, YOU SHOULD ALL BE
OUTRAGED.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS, WE DO HAVE
AMAZING NEWS TO SHARE WITH YOU
TONIGHT.
IT IS NOW THE 500TH DAY SINCE
DONALD TRUMP WAS INAUGURATED AND
AFTER MONTHS OF PREDICTIONS THAT
A TRUMP PRESIDENCY WOULD LEAD
THIS COUNTRY IN RUINS, IT'S NOW
UNDENIABLE THAT THE ENTIRE WORLD
IS SEEING MASSIVE, SERIOUS
PROGRESS UNDER THE PRESIDENT'S
LEADERSHIP.
PENDING TALKS WITH THE
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR, JUST DAYS
AWAY.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA, THAT WEIGHS IN THE
BALANCE IN THE INTERIM.
LET'S SEE?
KIM JONG IL AND HAS HALTED
KIM JONG UN HAS HALTED ALL HIS
MISSILE TEST, NUMBER MISSILES
FIRED OVER JAPAN IN THE INTERIM.
HIS NUCLEAR TEST SITES HAVE BEEN
DISABLED.
THREE AMERICAN HOSTAGES WERE
ALSO RETURNED.
HE WALKED OVER TO THE DMZ INTO
THE ARMS OF THE SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT.
ALL GOOD NEWS WHO IS NOT A DIME
PAID, LIKE IN THE CASE OF OBAMA
OR CLINTON IN SHOWING PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH WORKS.
ALSO BREAKING TODAY, THREE
LONGTIME NORTH KOREAN GENERALS
HAVE BEEN FIRED BY KIM JONG UN.
IN OTHER GOOD, POTENTIAL SIGN OF
NORTH KOREA'S COMMITMENT TOWARDS
SERIOUS REPORTING.
MEANWHILE, DAY 500, THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY -- WE'VE SEEN SO MANY
GREAT DEVELOPMENTS RIGHT HERE AT
HOME BUT WE DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
TIME TO LIST THEM.
LOOK AT THE SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN.
NEARLY 3 MILLION PLUS JOBS OR
BEEN CREATED, 300,000 IN
MANUFACTURING ALONE, THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE, ALMOST ON
PRESIDENT 3.8%, LOWEST IN 50
YEARS.
AMERICANS -- AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ALL TIME LOW UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IN THE SAME WITH HISPANIC
AMERICANS, SAME FOR WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, 14 STATE RECORD LOWS
AS IT RELATES TO UNEMPLOYMENT.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE, 17 YEAR
HIGH.
THIS AFTER PASSING A HISTORIC
$3.7 TRILLION TAX CUT AND
CUTTING 22 REGULATIONS FOR EVERY
NEW ONE AND ACTED.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES," OF
ALL PLACES, WRITING THAT WE RAN
OUT OF WORDS TO DESCRIBE HOW
GOOD THESE JOB NUMBERS ARE.
THEY CAN USE THE END AND EVEN
HAD TO REPORT THAT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE MATCHES ITS
LOWEST IN HALF A CENTURY.
OTHER ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDE
THE PRESIDENT KEEPING HIS
ACCOMPANIMENTS.
THE EMBASSY MOVED TO
-- YOU CANNOT FORGET ABOUT
TRUMP'S ACTIONS AGAINST ASSAD,
ISIS, AND A
ISIS, AND Á-LETTER
VLADAMIR PUTIN.
REMEMBER, SUCCESSFUL APPOINTMENT
OF NEIL GORSUCH.
I COULD GO ON AND ON.
IT WOULD TAKE ON THE WHOLE SHOW.
LOOK AT ZOGBY.
YET, THE ELITES IN THIS COUNTRY,
THE DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA,
HOLLYWOOD, OTHERS ALL WARNING
YOU WITH THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WOULD BE BAD FOR AMERICA.
YOU KNEW BETTER.
BAD FOR THE WORLD.
ACTIVELY ROOTING FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO FAIL SO THEY COULD
GET POWER BACK AT WHAT THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND IS AMERICANS
ARE FED UP WITH BOTH PARTIES,
THEY ARE DISGUSTED, SO THEY
PURPOSELY ELECTED A ICONOCLAST,
IT IS ROUGH THERE, SOMEONE THEY
KNEW WOULD GET RESULTS AND MAKE
DECISIONS.
MOVE WITH THE SPEED OF TRUMP.
IN ITS FIRST 500 DAYS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS PROVED HIS FIRST
NAYSAYERS WRONG.
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION TO ASK HIM
WHO DO YOU TRUST?
THE ANTI-TRUMP SYCOPHANTS WHO
HAVE BEEN WRONG OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, ACTIVELY NOW IN
THE POSITION OF HAVING TO ROOT
FOR FAILURE OF THE PRESIDENT
QUESTION MIKE THAT MEANS FAILURE
FOR THE COUNTRY?
EITHER WAY, A GUY THAT HAS
GOTTEN RESULTS?
THE ANSWER THIS QUESTION IS